aidan in Kentucky are on the bench Bo
struggle for Hayden hey Ben how you
doing it's good to talk to you I just
had a question I wanted to know what
having a newborn is like and if you have
any advice on becoming a father
me and my wife we're having a baby in a
few weeks so oh wow congratulations
exciting stuff yeah thank you well it
completely destroys and also create your
life so it is both it will completely
destroy whatever social life you have it
will completely destroy your capacity to
have fun outside the house for at least
several months and then it is the best
thing ever because kids are just they're
incredible they're the best thing
that'll ever happen to you and also the
worst thing that will ever happen to you
because when something happens that puts
your child in a position of pain it is
the worst thing in the world I have
three of them now and I can safely say
when something bad happens to my kids it
is significantly worse than when
something bad happens to me it is not
close on any level now as far as what a
newborn is like I'm gonna say the
unpopular thing newborns are incredibly
boring they're incredibly boring like my
wife is much more into newborns I found
that women I know are much more into
newborns men I know are not as into
newborns they're really boring at the
very beginning all they want to do
because all they can do is basically
poop crying eat that's it and you're not
gonna be able to do anything because you
don't have the the gears to make sure
that the baby gets fed so basically
you'll be holding the baby and
supporting your wife for the for the
next couple of months at least until the
baby can feed from a bottle and it takes
a little while for that to happen and
it's like three or four weeks until you
can really start feeding the baby from
bottle or they recommend it and at that
point things change for me for my kids
when I started to fall in love really
with my kids is when they could actually
react when they when they could smile
back at you but some people have a
different reaction some people see their
baby and first thing they feel is just
this overwhelming surge of love I will
say that that for me the the love was
slightly later when they started
becoming interesting but the surge of
protective feeling that immediately
happens as soon as the baby comes out
you're like okay this is something I'm
willing to die for and then when the
kids become interesting it's fantastic
and the older they get the better it is
I mean it's been so much more fun hey I
can talk with my oldest daughter and my
son and we can have really interesting
conversations they can be into things
they're interested in the world you get
to teach them they ask you questions you
never thought that you're gonna be
having to answer it makes you a better
person having kids does make it a better
person it's it's so awesome it really is
tastic and again I don't want to
downplay the downsides the downsides are
they're incredibly expensive they're a
giant pain in the butt they ruin your
personal life but they're also the
greatest thing that'll ever happen to
you
awesome thank you so much Ben and thanks
for entertaining me throughout the work
week as well you're the best Aidan I
really appreciate it thanks so much for
the call